live on sky news thank you so much for
talking to us i mean we are live
fantastic well done guys and very
british weather for people well it's
kind of it's kind of in a way it's it's
perfect in a way isn't it you want the
rain you want a bit of drizzle yeah
they say on a wedding day it's the lucky
so it must be lucky tonight let's hope
so i mean you said you were leaving
then you had to wait 18 months for it to
come out has it just felt like an
extraordinary long time no because we've
had kovitz so everything has to be put
into perspective doesn't it it's um i'm
greatly relieved we make bomb movies for
the cinema and uh and we're here and uh
i couldn't be happy about that i mean
there's quite a nice touch that actually
in the audience rather than autograph
hunters you've got members of the armed
forces we've got nhs that's what we
wanted to do we couldn't have full
crowds here tonight tonight so we
hand-picked yeah i mean i know you won't
be able to tell me a thing about the
film itself coming out it would say it's
out this week go see it is it bigger and
better
yes of course it is yes yes also i mean
this film comes post me too it's
different to when spector came out that
was something that you actually wanted
to acknowledge in this wasn't it i mean
so i missed the question sorry it's host
me too you wanted to address the fact
that the world's changed really first
listen bond movies have always reflected
the politics the time the style of the
time music whatever it is and we we
wouldn't you know
we
of course it's crept in because that's
the way we write these things so but um
nothing's been done too deliberately i
hope how has this 15-year ride been for
you i mean at times
the attention must have been just too
much to take but as you're walking away
does it feel i don't have any i
genuinely don't have any bad memories i
really don't everything's outweighed by
the good
but i keep saying i think it's going to
take about another 15 years for me to
unpick all this so
um i'll you know
how will you feel when the next name is
announced
will you offer any words of advice not
at all i mean thankfully it's not my
problem so um
i'm uh you know i just get on with it um
take it somewhere brilliant make it your
own just really looking forward to
audiences seeing this yeah brilliant
thank you so much